rien n'est dû au hasard
mon père nous a dit que cette vallée
notre bénédiction et donc nous y
resterons nous seront protégés
sortez de chez vous je sortir de l'eau
vous en prie ou sur les ombres
doit bien y avoir une explication ça n'a
aucun sens
pourquoi faire ça la main je sais pas
conduire ça et plus d'essence les pompes
ça ça prend du courage il ya une façon
de faire marcher manuellement
je suis d'accord qu'il est important de
penser à l'avenir
je glisse choses aillent bien en train
de il sépare fait qu'un patois
le plateau
what
sachez que je ne veux pas de mal je
m'appelle calais non tout va bien il
peut être n'importe qui au passage tout
comme cette vallée pourquoi avons-nous
survécu c'est parce qu'on a la foi
que quand tu faire je vois comment toi
et calais vous vous regardez si tu veux
explorer je tombais pas si c'est ça qui
te faut
va certainement malentendu je voulais
juste et ne plus être celle la jalousie
c'est nouveau papa je t'aime mais parier
sur qu'il nous deux va l'abattre